(Critic screaming)
(Abruptly stops screaming)
Ok, first question. Uh, yeah?
Oh, yeah, no, that's a lot of fun, yeah.
...and that's the first time I ever did it with a melon.
So, I just wanted to say, everybody, thank you so much.
(Applause)
(Critic screaming)
Nostalgia Critic?
SciFi Guy.
What are you doing h...(muffled)
It's him.
(Muffled) Who?
Linkara.
Linkara?!
Lower your voice, SciFi Guy!
He can smell geek.
My God.
Linkara.
Why, in Star Trek circles, he's known simply as:
Yes. The ultimate Star Trek nerd.
He has heard about my Star Trek Month.
He wants to do a crossover review with me on Star Trek: Insurrection.
But I won't let him. No no no.
All his stupid little nitpickiness that nobody
cares about is not going to spoil my review,
and I have found a perfect hiding spot.
He will never look for me here.
(Laughing)
(Slows to chuckling, then stops)
(Awkward, ain't it?)
Funny, I kinda thought something would happen while we were laughing, there.
Uh, yeah, like we'd be interrupted, or...
Yeah like someone would interrupt our laughing, yeah.
So, you want some coffee?
That'd be lovely, thank you.
Might as well see what's on the television.
[STATIC]
["Ironside" intro theme]
Hello, Critic. Start the review.
(Crying)
Last time, in the good Star Trek movie...(Sobbing)
Picard goes through a Borg Identity!
Obsessed with stopping his old arch-rivals -
even though he's never really been that obsessed
before -
he follows the Borg back in time to stop man's first contact with the Vulcans!
After ripping off Moby Dick, because,
that's what Star Trek likes to do,
Picard defeats the Borg queen,
Data goes through his "I wanna be human" bullshit again,
and first contact is still made by the farmer from Babe.
Will Star Trek continue to score big with audiences?
I don't care, I get paid either way!
[Kirk screams "Khan!" over and over to the opening theme of Star Trek II: The Wrath of Khan]
And now, we come to the final film in Star Trek Month, Star Trek: Insurrection,
with special guest star, Linkara.
Hello, adoring fans.
I've come all the way here on my spaceship to talk to you about the most hated of all Star Trek films.
Wait a minute. This one's the most hated?
I thought it was either, like, the first one or five that was the most despised.
That may be the case with other fans, but me personally,
this is my least favorite in the entire franchise.
So you need me here, or else you'll screw this review up like you've done so many times before.
What?! When have I ever screwed something up ?
(Oh, boy)
In your Battlefield Earth review, you said the Psychlos NEVER have explosions on their planet,
when that's not what they said in the movie!
It was that the air they breathed reacted violently to radiation!
My God, you're defending Battlefield Earth?
No, I'm pointing out the fact that you never get details right.
So we're gonna do this TOGETHER, so it gets done CORRECTLY.
So, let's not waste any time.
Let's dive right into...
(SciFi Guy clears throat)
Am I in this?
Well it's...kinda just a duo thing.
But it's...my room.
Yeah...
Ok, I...guess I'll just go...stand silently in the corner.
Star Trek: Insurrection.
So we open on the Shire as we see a peaceful alien people called the Ba'ku, taking care of their planet.
LINKARA: Funny how these people who don't believe in machines have an irrigation system set up for their crops.
It's almost as if machines are helpful or something.
And, on top of that, the original s eries got away with people who looked exactly like Humans
because it was a low-budget 60's TV series.
This is a multimillion-dollar movie.
Buy some damn forehead bumps or something!
CRITIC: But we see there's Starfleet personnel in invisible suits keeping track of the people in the city.
VOICE OVER INTERCOM:
The android! He's out of control!
My God, it's Jambi!
(as Data) Meka-leka die, meka die you ho!
LINKARA: He takes a phaser and reveals the Federation's base,
which is remarkably close, isn't it?
Wouldn't it make more sense to monitor them in space so that nobody bumps into it?
CRITIC: And what, did they do the construction in invisible suits?
They never heard the invisible bulldozers put it together?
LINKARA: But, heck with that, we have this subplot that goes nowhere.
RIKER: Our guests have arrived. They're eating the floral arrangements on the banquet tables.
CRUSHER: I guess they don't believe in cocktails before dinner.
TROI: Are they vegetarian? That's not in there!
PICARD: Perhaps we should have the chef whip up a light balsamic vinaigrette,
something that goes well with chrysanthemums.
Wow, that was four lines in a row dedicated to plants.
Gives you some idea of the thrill ride we're in for with this movie.
TROI: Remember, they have a significantly less advanced technology than ours.
They only achieved warp drive last year.
CRUSHER: And the Federation Council decided to make them a protectorate so quickly?
PICARD: In view of our losses to the Borg and the Dominion, the Council feels we need all the allies we can get these days.
Remember this, I'll have a tangent on it later.
What, did he say the word "Dominion" wrong or something?
Yes, but that's beside the point, we'll get to it later.
WORF: Captain.
PICARD: Mr. Worf.
WORF: Doctor.
CRUSHER: Worf!
PICARD: What the hell are you doing here?
WORF: I was at the Manzar Colony...
RIKER: He's a little late, Geordi, can it wait?
LA FORGE: I don't think so...
CRITIC (as Picard): It doesn't matter, you're here, we'll cast you.
PICARD: Welcome aboard the Enterprise.
CUZAR: Captain Picard, may I welcome you in the time-honored tradition of my people.
LINKARA: So he meets up with the Oompa Loompa queen,
and she partakes in the tradition of making bald men look like Dorothy from "The Wizard of Oz."
PICARD: But Data should've been back by now.
They were only scheduled to observe
the Ba'ku village for one week.
CRITIC: But Picard-ahontas...
LINKARA: I would've gone with Jean-Lucagawea.
CRITIC: Ok, that's pretty good.
...is told about Data and has to go figure out what's wrong.
PICARD: Geordi, would you set up a secure comlink with the admiral in the anteroom?
LA FORGE: Aye, sir.
ADISLO: Uh, captain? Hars Adislo, we met at the
Nel Bato conference last year.
Did you ever have a chance to read my paper
on thermionic transconductance?
PICARD: Would you excuse me?
Who was that guy?!
I don't know.
Well you've seen all the shows, has he ever popped up?
Not that I'm aware of.
Well, maybe he'll explain it in his next scene.
He doesn't HAVE a next scene.
You mean...he just completely...
...vanishes.
Who are you, blue man?
DOUGHERTY: Commander Data attacked us in the mission scoutship yesterday.
I know what Data means to Starfleet, Jean-Luc,
but our crew is at the mercy of those people on the planet.
PICARD: If our first attempt to capture Data fails,
I will terminate him.
CRITIC: At least give us one more movie before we kill him.
DOUGHERTY: All right.
PICARD (singing): Come out, come out, wherever you are...
WORF: Sir?
That's something that my m...
LINKARA: Well, that was a thrilling backstory.
CRITIC: Yeah, I wonder what other character insights we're gonna glance over.
You know, this reminds me of when
I was a little girl in Alaska...
Oh! What was that?!
PICARD: We've seen how he reponds to threats, I wonder how he would respond...
CRITIC: So in a maneuver I don't really understand,
they figure out singing to him will somehow break his programming.
PICARD: (Singing) A British tar is a soaring soul/
His nose should pant/
DATA (singing): And his lip should curl/
PICARD: His cheeks should flame/
DATA: And his brow should furl/
PICARD, DATA, AND WORF:
His nose should pant/And his lip should curl/
Ok, has Star Trek just become a musical?
Between "Row, Row, Row Your Boat," "Life Forms," and this,
I've heard less singing in Sesame Street!
I mean, what Star Trek fan would actually enjoy this...
(Singing) His eyes should flash with an inborn fire/
His brow with scorn be rung/
DATA (singing): He never should bow down to a domineering frown/
LINKARA: I love the classics.
PICARD (singing): Or the...
CRITIC: So the singing surprisingly does work,
as the team beams down, where they see the Ba'ku playing a friendly game of CG-ball.
PICARD: We were under the impression they were
being held against their will.
SOJEF: The artificial life form
would not allow them to leave.
PICARD: Apparently he was taken ill.
TOURNEL: There was a phase variance in his positronic matrix which we were unable to repair.
ANIJ: I think the captain finds it hard to believe that we'd have any skills repairing a positronic device.
Well, yeah, since you clearly explained that you don't use technology.
SOJEF: Our technological abilities are not apparent because we have chosen not to employ them in our daily lives.
We believe that when you create a machine to do the work of a man, you take something away from the man.
Then how can you know the latest technology?!
Don't get me wrong, I understand studying technology, but,
how can you keep up with the latest technology on a planet forbidding technology
without any goddamn technology?!
-Magic.
-Shut up!
ANIJ: But, at one time, we explored the galaxy, just as you do.
PICARD: You have warp capability?
Capability, yes.
But where can warp drive take us, except away from here?
CRITIC: Yeah, I guess if Star Trek has taught us anything, it's that space IS pretty boring.
LINKARA: I'm sorry, but I'm not behind this, at least not in the way these pompous jerks are flaunting it.
First of all, you HAVE machines.
We saw your irrigation line, you idiots.
And those clothes look pretty
damn well tailored for people
who don't have the ability to manufacture them properly.
Second, this movie builds this place up as paradise, as Eden or perfection.
However, their philosophy is the complete opposite
of what Star Trek stands for!
Star Trek, in the end, is about how advanced technology has done us so much good,
allows us to do so many great things,
and that the future is a bright one, partially because we want for nothing.
This movie, however, tells us we need to get back to nature
and be smug hippie jackasses who reject technology and machines
in favor of being so inbred that we don't believe in any other colors for our clothes except brown!
Yikes, Linkara.
I'm sorry, but I really hate these people! They piss me off!
What, do you hate Amish people, too?
No, they hate me.
But at least the Amish have religious reasons for rejecting technology.
These guys are just dumb.
We see them using tools,
and in the end, what is technology but just advanced tools?
Well, on the bright side, it's not like we have to deal with them that often...
They're the focus of the movie.
Fuck!
CRITIC: But the atmosphere of the planet starts playing with the crew's molecular structure, which makes everybody get all,
for lack of a better word,
pubert-ish.
Worf grows a pimple,
Picard gets all energetic,
and half the crew starts acting like horny kids.
TROI: Yuck!
RIKER: Yuck?
I never kissed you with a beard before.
Ahem.
What was that?
That was a clip from the show.
Oh God, don't tell me...
Yes, I have every episode of Star Trek in my ship's data banks.
I intend to use them throughout this review whenever the continuity seems off.
Come to think of it, we could probably have used that a few scenes ago. Mind if we go back?
(Screams)
I'll take that as a "no."
LA FORGE: All I know is that he was functioning normally until he was shot.
Then his fail-safe system was activated.
PICARD: Fail-safe?
His ethical and moral subroutines took over all of his basic functions.
But you're saying that he still knew the difference between right and wrong.
In a sense, that's ALL he knew.
CRITIC: Yes, because the ethical battles of right and wrong are now easily-programmable facts in the future.
Hey Data, which of these is ethically sound?
Abortion, stem cell research, death penalty...
That's what I thought.
LINKARA: But they get Data back to normal and he takes them to the last place he remembers before his programming went wacky.
DATA: I believe I know what is causing the neutrino emissions!
LINKARA: Yup, no machines, except for this giant machine-looking thing here to drain the lake.
But that's as common as a garden hoe, isn't it?
Oh, and did I mention they have a dam, too?
That's right, a dam, as in, "these are some damn big hypocrites!"
CRITIC: They discover an invisible ship with a holodeck replica of their town in it -
LINKARA: Another thing that they could've just worked on in space.
CRITIC: but some bad guys see them and start to attack.
You know, for as exciting as this all is,
I honestly just keep thinking back to whatever happened to that blue guy.
What WERE his theories of thermionic transconductance?
LINKARA: Much more thought-provoking questions than the rest of this movie is asking.
ANIJ: Help! I can't swim!
(Critic groans)
-What?!
Are you kidding me?
Is water technology now? Are you resisting the shackles of H2O?
And on top of that, it turns out she's had PLENTY of time to learn how to swim.
We discover that several of the adults there are over 300 years old.
That's what the metaphasic radiation of the planet does.
LINKARA: Yeah, what the hell's her excuse?!
PICARD: In 300 years, you never learned to swim?
ANIJ: I just haven't got around to it yet.
You are stupid!
CRITIC: So, basically, the Federation wants to use the planet as a means to find cures and other medical miracles.
Sounds good. So, what, have they talked to these
people about working together, or--
LINKARA: Nope, they just plan to beam them off the planet when they're asleep.
CRITIC: Odd. Well, I'm sure now that they know the Ba'ku
are willing to help others
by letting them study the planet...
LINKARA: Nope! They see it as their home. They hate technology, we have technology, therefore, they hate us.
CRITIC: Ok, well, I guess that's legit seeing how it's their planet...
LINKARA: It's not.
The fuck you talking about?!
LINKARA: Yeah, technically the planet is under Federation control,
and they say that they came there 300 years ago from their own home planet,
so they don't own squat.
Well then, why the hell don't they just kick these
greedy cure for death holders out, then?
So Picard can make speeches like this:
PICARD: Some of the darkest chapters in the history of my world
involve the forced relocation of a small group of people.
Just as cultures have been destroyed in every other forced relocation throughout history.
Oh really?!
Is that why you participated in
at least TWO forced relocations?!
And guess what? One of them was a group of Indians,
AND he was going to do the
EXACT SAME PLAN as they're doing here!
WAKASA: Do you know how long we have searched for a home?
PICARD: I believe that I can help you to find a new home.
LINKARA: But hey, these are white people and not Native Americans, so it's totally different, I guess.
CRITIC: Yeah, that's true.
There's a group of stretchy-faced people that are looking to harness the planet's power because they're dying,
yet these selfish jerks are like, "you use an electric razor? You deserve to croak."
DOUGHERTY: We're only moving 600 people.
PICARD: How many people does it take, admiral, before it becomes wrong?
Six hundred and one, obviously.
DOUGHERTY: We'll be able to use the regenerative properties of this radiation to help BILLIONS.
And I'm sorry, but I gotta reference my clips again.
(Screams)
LINKARA: This is what I was referring to before:
at the same time this movie came out,
the series Deep Space Nine was on,
(Critic continues screaming)
and during that series, the Federation was at war with a powerful enemy called the Dominion,
and the Federation was losing.
Badly.
And according to their projections, if the Federation loses,
800 billion people will die!
And I'm sorry, but ah, doesn't Star Trek have a particular clip for this kind of thing?
SPOCK: The needs of the many...
outweigh...
KIRK: The needs of the few.
I'm sorry, but, I'm completely on the side of the bad guys here.
Critic?
(Groans)
Huh? Huh? What?!
I'm done.
The movie's over?
No.
Screw you then.
CRITIC: All right, so Picard decides to go down alone.
LINKARA: If he's going down alone,
why does he have all those guns?
He can't carry them all, and the Ba'ku
already said that they won't use weapons.
CRITIC: Well, because he knows his crew is gonna throw the same bullshit that every Star Trek crew throws.
(as Picard) I don't want you to come.
(as La Forge) We're coming.
(as Picard) Ok.
(Normal voice) Oh, and don't forget the totally-out-of-nowhere trailer line from Data.
DATA: Saddle up.
Lock and load.
ASH: Yeeeeeah, baby!
CRITIC: So they're leading the people
away from the town...
wait, isn't that what the bad guys wanted, anyway?
kind of doing them a favor, aren't you?
LINKARA: I'm just wondering where the sun is in this solar system.
We never saw it in any of the space shots.
CRITIC: But then the villains come in to hit them with darts and force them to get beamed out.
But, why don't you just beam them out regularly?
ARTIM: Father!
LINKARA: But they get away -
I'm guessing, they just sort of cut off screen and then they're somewhere else -
as Data tries to comfort the boy who just lost his father.
ARTIM: Do machines ever play?
DATA: Yes. I play the violin.
Look, if you want to know what it's like to be a child, you need to learn to play.
CRITIC: Oh yeah, he sounds traumatized.
LINKARA: Hey no, everybody treats grief differently.
Some choose to accept it, by...
not realizing they have it at all.
CRITIC: We also see Picard, and...
boring woman who won't be in any future movies so it doesn't matter,
start to hit it off.
PICARD: I should warn you, I've always been attracted to older women.
How are you doing this?
ANIJ: No more questions.
LINKARA: Uh, yeah questions! Lots of questions!
CRITIC: Yeah, this is science fiction. At least SOME questions have to be answered!
Nothing? Nothing at all?
Ok, she's a wizard.
Anyway, we see more Mega Man robots catch up with them, and they try hiding in a cave.
(as a Ba'ku) Thanks for saving us with your technology; by the way, we hate technology.
LINKARA: While that's going on, the bad guys are attacking the Enterprise, while Riker tries to escape them.
CRITIC: You ever notice a pattern in these movies?
Picard leaves the ship, and Riker always destroys it.
RIKER: Computer! Access manual steering column!
Transfer helm controls to manual.
LINKARA: A joystick. Riker is piloting the ship with a joystick.
This has just become a half-assed Wing Commander game, folks!
CRITIC: Now, let's be fair, a real video game version of this film would be far worse.
(Critic voiceover)
You are, of course, wrong.
But they then get stuck in a cave, and a bunch of rocks fall on top of that boring lady.
LINKARA: Picard then says dialogue that even Rick Astley wouldn't put in one of his love songs.
PICARD: Stay with me.
Help me find the power to keep you in this moment.
Stay with me.
Don't let go of this moment.
["Never Gonna Give You Up" in the background]
(Singing) Stay with me/Don't let go of this moment/
LINKARA: But then, something remarkable happens, I guess.
She slows down the moment so that the others can arrive in time.
CRITIC: Oh, I thought she was gonna have an emotion.
LINKARA: Hey, I said remarkable, not a miracle.
CRUSHER: She's stabilizing.
CRITIC (as Anij): Oh, thanks for saving me with your medical technology; by the way, I hate technology.
(Normal voice) I'm sorry, I'm still wondering what happened to that blue guy.
Were they important theories? Would they change the dynamics of anything?
LINKARA: So in a twist - or at least I think that's what they're calling it -
it turns out that the dying race called the Son'a are the exact same race as the Ba'ku.
They just left the planet so they didn't have the healing powers that the Ba'ku had.
CRITIC: So, as you can see, the ethical standpoint of this movie is SO WEAK
that they HAD to make up other reasons to hate the bad guys.
LINKARA: But you can also tell he's the villain by the fact that he looks like Salieri's skin melting.
CRITIC: Oh yeah, I forgot, that's F. Murray Abraham, isn't it?
LINKARA: It's ok, I think even he forgot he was F. Murray Abraham in this picture.
GALLATIN: Moving them is one thing. Killing them all?
RU'AFO: No one hated them more than you, Gal'na.
CRITIC: So it's a little confusing,
but pretty much everyone keeps ship hopping,
and they fool the Son'a by beaming them onto a holodeck,
which is programmed to look like the bridge of their ship.
LINKARA: They just happened to have that program in there?
CRITIC (as Anij): No more questions, Linkara.
COMPUTER: Unable to comply. Injector assembly one has been deactivated.
RU'AFO: No!!
LINKARA: He screams like a baby elephant, and then goes over to the collector device for the rings,
and then Picard beams over there and they have a really crappy action scene,
blah blah blah.
PICARD: You're really going to risk igniting the exhaust?
All right. I will!
RU'AFO: No!
CRITIC: Most useless. Villain. Ever.
LINKARA: So Picard is beamed up, the ship is destroyed, and we get our one funny line in the movie:
WORF: The Son'a crew would like to negotiate a ceasefire.
It may have something to do with the fact that we have three minutes of air left.
I'm so bored by the rest of this, I can't even bring myself to laugh at that.
LINKARA: We also see that Data has discovered playing!
Seven years of character development on a TV show and three movies and it all comes down to PLAYING.
ARTIM: Don't forget:
you have to have a little fun, every day.
LINKARA: Start by not watching this movie.
Linkara, I'm not gonna lie.
I do think that's the worst one.
You see?
CRITIC: Even if you took out the ethical discussions,
the film as a whole is just a bore.
The action is dull, the effects are dull,
it's paced more like a really lame episode than it is a feature film.
It just feels like nothing was accomplished,
and even the worst Star Trek movies left me with, something,
at least one or two interesting moments.
But this is totally forgettable and has nothing backing it.
And in a way, for a Star Trek movie, you could argue that is the worst crime you could ever commit.
Oh wait wait wait, we still have all the problems of Nemesis to go through,
and I'm not just talking continuity errors here...
Oh God, Linkara, have you no heart?
SCIFI GUY: Hey.
Why don't you turn off the TV?
Oh, yeah.
I've got plenty of...what the fu-?!
All right, SciFi Guy, you've been there long enough, I think you've learned your lession.
What lesson? I didn't do anything.
-Wanna go back in the corner?
-No.
Well, thanks everybody for joining me for Star Trek Month, I hope you enjoyed it, and...
(Boos)
All right, all right, I'll quickly go over Star Trek: Nemesis.
This is the film that everyone says is the other bad Trek film,
but, to be fair, I don't think it's that bad.
It's got some annoying scenes and way too much action, but,
the whole idea of nature literally vs. nurture I thought was kind of fascinating.
I liked the idea that Picard had to battle his younger self,
and that, in a different environment, maybe he could've been something entirely different.
And the relationship between the two, I think in many respects, is actually kind of heartbreaking.
To me, that's the glue that held the movie together.
Is it good? Technically, on a storytelling level, probably not.
But, I have to admit, I enjoyed watching it, for the most part,
but, yeah, I'll admit, as an ending for the Next Generation franchise,
it probably wasn't all that it could be.
I mean, it could have been a hell of a lot worse. It could be Star Trek: Insurrection!
-Well, I think...
-Go to the corner!
[Star Trek II theme]
ANIJ: No more questions.